katia bonjour alors malgré les récentes
annonces du gouvernement les soignants
res de mobiliser
oui absolument pour le moment les
premières annonces sont pas du tout
satisfaits
les personnels soignants que qui sont
dans la rue aujourd'hui à l'appel des
syndicats fo cgt unsa et également sud
et du collectif inter urgences et des
collectifs inter hôpitaux alors ils sont
dans leur est aujourd'hui boulevard du
montparnasse des milliers de personnes
avec un encadrement policier très
stricte en fait les les gendarmes marche
des deux côtés la de du cortège là nous
sommes en direction du ministère de la
santé
ce n'est pas pour rien évidemment vous
savez que les concertations du ségur qui
ont démarré le 25 mai vont s'achever
vendredi
ces concertations pour un plan un massif
de revalorisation de l'hôpital ont été
souhaitées par emmanuel macron elles ont
été pilotées par l'ancienne directrice
de la cfdt nicole notât
pour le moment le ministre de la santé
olive et veyran a annoncé plus de 6
milliards pour des augmentations de
salaires pour les personnels non
médicaux alors par exemple les
infirmiers les aides soignants les
manipulateurs radio dont des majorations
des refontes de primes tout ça dans
cette enveloppe de 6 milliards mais
selon les syndicalistes que nous avons
interviewé aujourd'hui eh bien ça ne
suffit pas le compte n'y est pas d'où
cette mobilisation pour tenter de peser
jusqu au dernier moment
je vous propose d'écouter de patron de
syndicats y verriez de fo et philippe
martinez de la cgt c'est des actes qui
sont à la hauteur des remerciements des
encouragements des
le tous de tous les lauriers cons là
qu'on a on a entendu durant a durant ces
deux mois je viens là donner une
médaille mais on n'achète pas son pack
des médailles
on a l'impression que plus le
gouvernement donne des aides accorde des
prêts aux entreprises et plus il ya des
suppressions d'emplois j'avais cru
comprendre que ces aides ces prêts
c'était non seulement c'était pour
maintenir au moins maintenir l'emploi
voir le développer donc j'ai
l'impression qu'on est reparti comme
avant en quoi c'est des licenciements
boursiers
parce qu'on pense d'abord aux
actionnaires et puis l'emploi les
salariés les citoyens là ça passe après
la l'instant effectivement on a une
annonce de l' enveloppe de 2,6 milliards
et vous savez que notre revendication
principale c'est 300 euros pour tous et
si on fait 300 euros pour tous et sur le
million de spitz a lié ces déjà 7,2
milliards au minimum donc aujourd'hui
les 6 milliards ne peuvent pas nous
satisfaire
surtout qu'on attend aussi une
revalorisation des grilles des
infirmiers aides-soignants ce qui fait
qu'il fallait largement au delà des 6
milliards donc on sera reçue normalement
demain par opérant pour des négociations
nouvelle et on espère bien qu'il y
aurait une rallonge
budgétaire parce que sinon ça va pas
faire la beaujoire
donc les revendications des soignants ne
sont pas évidemment que des
augmentations de salaires bien sûr ils
veulent aussi des embauches l'arrêt des
restructurations qui a renforcé les
déserts médicaux et qui rend plus
difficile l'accès aux soins
et puis également l'arrêt des fermetures
de lits donc aujourd'hui des milliers de
soignants ont répondu à l'appel à cette
grande mobilisation du 16 juin les
syndicats banques encore rencontré le
président veut encore négocier jusqu'au
bout et nous suivons cette manifestation
jusqu'au ministère de la santé merci
beaucoup
katia on vous retrouve bien évidemment
tout au long de l'après-midi katia
technique au coeur de la manifestation
des soignants à paris